hi everybody i'm jonathan shrine's today
we're gonna be testing out a new format
here in Studio B and what we're gonna do
here is I'm just gonna play a
five-minute game on chess that calm
we're hoping in the future we'll get
some of our grandmasters or residents to
come down here play blitz so we're just
gonna try to test that make sure the
audio we're just the video works that
sort of thing I'm just gonna play a
quick game let us know any any questions
you have I'm gonna click play here
anything you guys would like to see is
their favorite time control or duration
of the video
pretty tough opponent here Hannibal for
looks like it's a bit higher rated than
me so we'll just play a Sicilian here
this is something I've got some I
recently let's try to remember my own
tricky analysis of this line here
there's some gambit I can play after a
694 if b5 I'll go here so obviously he
can play b4 and he can take this pawn
and then the strong move here is a 3
this is actually a very rare line so he
has to do something now either b3 or
take on a3 he decided to take and I
should get a lot of pressure for the
pawn I got pressure on the queenside and
it's very tricky though so I don't
exactly know what to expect here I
haven't looked at this line in years so
something I prepared for an opponent
quite a long time ago this is a lion
Anand has played this way I believe his
opponent played b3 though instead of
allowing the rook to be on this a file
so this is a little bit new to me I
believe in the game he put his bishop on
c4 and canceled and we'll see I also
with with my rook here I'm also I'm
thinking about playing Bishop to b5
attacking this pin piece and obviously
there's a pin on the a file so mister
Hannibal for us going into a little bit
of a thing here it is very tricky to
play black in this position but you are
up a pawn so you put this Bishop here so
I'm Bishop b5
Hey
I completely there should be five and
then hmm what should I do
well I'm just gonna go here Abby should
be fine I think he just has Bishop d7
and I'm not really sure what I'm doing
so I'm just gonna develop two here now I
can ask try to ask some questions to
this night before he gets cancelled here
well all right I'm just gonna Bluff
maybe I'm taking this pawn maybe I have
some discoveries here on this night
don't exactly see it but uh before he
castles I'm hoping to do something so
hopefully he's worried about me winning
his pond and he does something about it
it pushes a5 or something
obviously he doesn't have to he could
consider castling and I'll probably just
take the pawn back an a5 then I really
might play Bishop b5 looking for a good
a good way to go to this night maybe
just some my discovery on this guy don't
really see it you should play
thirty-five or just Castle he is
thinking which is good for me
and I mean this lines are really tricky
so if you've never really seen them and
i haven't don't remember any my prep or
anything but they can be tricky also may
be considering Knight to d4 which I've
only just now noticed ninety-four Queen
d3 is a bit interesting so I'm hoping he
plays a move like f5 obviously he
doesn't have to so I'm attacked I will
go back so I want to castle in place c3
this was I no longer I'm winning this
pawn so you can castle and I'm not even
threatening to win his pawn my place c3
I'll put this one in here to see where
his knight decides to go so I haven't
really proven that my pawn sack was
great or anything I still do have some
compensation OnPoint squares I have the
d5 square but this point it's starting
to look like he's just up upon I'll just
castle but big advantage is on the clock
though so I got to keep that up that's
uh that's the real way to win if you
want high quality chess you know what to
get the grandmasters down here if you
want to see flagging and bad chest and
blundering your pieces then this is the
right level for you but yeah it could be
a lot of fun and it may be for big
events maybe we can get some you know
some very strong players down here so
what am i doing
all right let's go try to get this
Bishop out maybe I'll put this guy and
b4 don't know goal is to not really
think very much that is my main goal
okay let's just hop around 85 I can play
96 and then maybe I can hop all the way
around very good I guess I'll develop
he's gonna start kicking all my stuff
around this can't possibly be good for
me but I still got that clock going so
let us know in the comments you guys do
you guys like five minutes one minute
three minutes 15 minutes should they
play one or two games should they play
lots of games we got a lot of stuff to
uh to figure out so really anything you
say even the name but we don't really
have a name for this segment so anything
you can come up with in that department
would be welcome
you know there's many other YouTube
channels that have similar features
where you play blitz and you talk about
it that have some some decent names if
you can think of something original you
know maybe you can change our our
channel here so I would have loved to
have moved my night obviously that would
have blundered checkmate I can take his
night or move my Queen have to get
serious here okay he's just gonna use a
bulldozer
okay he's attacking my knight he is
attacking my knight so that is on my
radar all right this is not looking
great this isn't that looking great all
right just give me that give me that oh
gosh it's pinned all right give me that
now there's a lot of pins oh well all
right there was a lot of pinning going
on there to play here is he threatening
f3 as threat mm-hmm listen stuff this is
tough edible here is very strong yeah
yeah if you went here I was gonna lock
that file and just get a little bit of
lift just in case if we can out speed
him here
so maybe he's gonna fry to plate well
maybe not that he's gonna travel h4 and
get astroturf no file so you can say
it's clean maybe if I rotate on takes I
go back this isn't that great but that's
not what happened so don't open that
okay he's putting his fish up here
that's an issue um well okay here we go
you'll never see that come in should be
able to win on time here all right
not a perfect game who's interesting
though I've actually been saving this
for a long time I've recently played
Alex Marla who used to be the assistant
manager here before me and he plays the
Kalashnikov a lot so I had this line
prepped this is something upon sack that
most people are not familiar with I know
after a three White's supposed to be
doing great
I think b3 is even stronger than here
but anyways it was it was pretty
difficult for him to play the position
also let us know to it do you guys want
after games do you guys like to see
analysis and that sort of things do you
want them to put the engine on and check
it all with the computer just let us
know everything you guys want we'll make
it happen that's what we do here so tell
us in the comments below what we should
be doing here with our new blitz segment
and I hit like share subscribe and and
let us know what you guys think thanks a
lot